الدفاع المدني الى حد هذه اللحظه في
عمليات البحث عن مفقودين تحت العلاقات
يؤسفنا ان نقول ان هذه الساعات هي ساعات
حرجه
بالنسبه للموجودين تحت الانقاذ مما
احتماليه حدود ماديين يؤخر على احتماليه
وجود نادين تحت الامطار فالان العمليات
البحث مستمره
عن المفقودين ولكن سوف
نستثني كلمه نادين لعده اسباب منها
انخفاض درجه حراره
اليوم الاضافه النزيف الحاد فاحتماليه
وجود نادين تحت الانفاق تتخلص للاسف
الا ان كان هناك في عمليات الهدم الذي
تحصل هكذا تكون عمليات هرس للجسم مما يؤدي
الى عمليات الى نزيف في يؤدي الى حاله
وفاه لذلك انا الدفاع المدني يعمل على 72
ساعه ذهبيه كما نقول دائما في عمليات
البحث والانقاذ دائما ما كنا نسعى في
ساعات الاولى ان تكون هذه المعدات التي
طالبت بها فرق البحث من الانقاذ ان تكون
موجوده لدينا منزل ساعات الاولى وليس بعد
72 ساعه والى الان وبعد ساعه لم تتمكن طرق
البحث والانقاذ في شمال سوريا من الحصول
على تلك المساعدات التي تساعد
المدنيين عاده